only you can appreciate the genius that
is you and everybody has a genius in
themselves because at the end of the day
you're not gonna die with the feelings
of these people you're gonna die
yourself right so you just have to love
who you are and do what you want to do
whatever makes you happy
if you want to achieve something or if
you want to do something you got to
speak into existence or like say you
want a car or you want something or you
want to be successful or whatever just
keep talking about it you know I mean
Just Keep On Believing in yourself and
say you know what I'm gonna do this so
you just always got to be confident and
always believe in what you what you do
and you know one day if you just keep
believing in yourself keep talking about
it and it just pops you know it's
overwhelming but you just gotta you just
gotta stay positive and keep calling and
don't let nobody get to you people are
so opinionated and people uh have way
too much to say and everybody's so smart
and everybody's a Critic everybody knows
everything you know it's like just like
if you don't know the situation don't
speak on it
at the same time you don't know what
someone is going through and you don't
know how easy it is just to get caught
up in something to the point where you
can't stop
and it's not your fault it's not it's
not you don't need somebody to talk down
to you or say oh you shouldn't do drugs
you need somebody to be there to give
you the support that you need as a
friend or a family member I don't even
know the half of what anybody's going
through but I just want to say it's
[ __ ] okay to reach out it's okay to
reach out to people because you're not
by yourself you're not alone you have
people around you who love you no matter
who you are and I know there's a lot of
lonely people and there's
um
um a trillion billion
lonely people in the world and I just
want to say that there's
um always someone who loves you and you
don't have to be scared to talk about it
I know that everybody
you know has had these feelings and
these thoughts and and the ups and downs
and and you know everybody has wanted to
just give up and be like I don't know
what the [ __ ] to do but also people have
celebrated the I don't care if you're
the grumpiest guy in the world you still
celebrated a a great time in your life
you know I was not a normal like my
brain was not operating at its normal uh
frequency I guess I don't know but it
was it just wasn't I wasn't Austin I was
like so [ __ ] lost yeah and who
brought you back me I think you're the
only person who can bring you back
everybody can surround you everybody can
say hey man it's you know what's going
on are you all right at the end of the
day you just have to take that love that
you're offered and say you know what it
is
we we spoke about it but it's very much
about
you being able to provide what you need
by yourself and not looking to anybody
else because for the longest time maybe
you know I was searching out for it when
it'll naturally come to you and like I
said you're you're the only you're the
only person at the end of the day that
can actually lift you up you just have
to realize that there's real [ __ ]
true
positivity and love out there and it's
and it's there you just can't search for
it so vigorously and and you're not
gonna find it if you don't like me
that's cool I got hella people that do
yeah and they love me and I love them
and they're gonna take me and then we're
gonna just you know I've had my fair
share of uh kids used to throw gum in my
hair but you know um it was tough
I had my own I was an individual and
people don't like that right people
don't like when you're different from
them and you go against the norm in
Middle School
I wore a suit to school every day I
wanted to be like my dad yeah I slick my
hair back every day I got picked on I
think success is like
having what you need
and being able to do what you want you
know whenever you want and just cut it
relaxing and being happy and soaking it
in you know yeah and I'm working on it
now I feel like everybody got beef
but I'm just trying to you know I'm
trying to get my own you know we can all
get we can all get money at the same
time there's a no there's well over
enough money in the world I have been
surrounded by music all different types
of music from from growing up from a
young boy in in New York with my brother
playing me hip-hop and my dad playing me
rock and you know I'm with the Texas and
my mom started playing me country and
everything going on but there was a
moment to where I lost my passion to
make music
you know it's like
it becomes a job I was just a kid you
know and making music and I had all
these songs and everything but
it became a job you know with
labels and touring and everything and it
gets so hard to actually focus on why
you're there and then it gets very hard
to
um
say am I actually doing this for me and
my fans or am I doing it to you know
have a living make a living you know
what I mean
um and losing focus losing momentum
losing Drive
um for a second I just didn't want to
make music and then something just
changed and I was like [ __ ] it man this
this is why I'm here but it got 2.2
where I was like yeah I do like music
that's like I love making music this is
what like
I'm I'm supposed to do like this is what
makes me happy it took it took a minute
to get to get back to that and I'm happy
happy we're there now and I love I love
making music again and I'm such a happy
happy loud I talked to somebody about
this recently too it's like it's almost
like you're watching your life but it's
a movie like you're watching it happen
it's like I don't remember who I was
talking to
um but it's called depersonalization or
something and I was like you feel that
way too and I was like oh [ __ ] and I
don't know it's just super strange man
it's rough like the it feels like a
heart attack and then you go to the
doctor's like plenty of times and you're
like what's wrong with me and they're
like nothing really right like but
you're like but I feel like [ __ ] my
message to the youth is
um don't give up there's a lot of people
like I say like I always say man there's
a lot of people that are going to try to
put you down and try to kick you while
you're down and they're going to tell
you that you ain't never gonna be
but just keep on rocking because I had
my times you know I had the dark times
very dark times but you know you always
gonna come out like like like a phoenix
bro you're gonna come out of the ashes
flying so high like the Flaming bird and
just keep on rocking always be yourself
always be original don't listen to what
anybody has to say because at the end of
the day
self-awareness it's you being happy with
who you are
keep on rocking keep on trucking
[Music]
truth do whatever you want
you know a lot of people laughed at me a
lot of people wanted to put me down
um and honestly to be able to to reach
out to people who might
you know not have anybody to turn to and
just be able to reach out and and show
everybody that they're not alone and
music can bring everybody together it's
absolutely incredible
I like I like writing songs that
um Loosely based on experiences but
songs that will I guess help out whoever
needs help you know and and and very
much so like people singing these songs
and and you know live and at the shows
and
um that's just such a great feeling
because to see how many people have
related to these songs and how many
people it's helped it's like it's just
super bitching man it's so cool